hey guys i am just mcdonald and it is
top five time which means not really do
you get this awesome friday but if you
missed out on some of the gaming bits
and pieces from over the week i'm here
to keep you updated let's get into it
first up if you love the last of us the
game then you'll love the last of us the
movie or it could be awful we'll find
out Naughty Dog creative director Neil
druckmann is writing the script and the
devs co-presidents as well as game
director Bruce Stanley will be involved
in some capacity Sony's own Screen Gems
production company will be attached to
the project as will Sam Raimi and his
ghost house pictures company let's face
it the big question though is who should
play Ellie and Joel if you've got an
idea for who should act opposite ellen
page then let me know i know corporate
industry business isn't everybody's bag
but playstation boss jack tretton
stepping down is absolutely huge news
the Sony Computer Entertainment CEO
helped launch every single PlayStation
that's ever been Sony have said that
Tretton stepping down was a mutual
decision and that CEO Sean Laden is set
to take over Trenton's role as of April
first according to Hideo Kojima the kids
are not so interested in triple-a games
anymore the Metal Gear creator has
identified a shift from young people
toward mobile and social titles and away
from triple-a especially from people in
Japan referencing Metal Gear 5 being
split into two parts kijima says that he
hopes to show people that playing
high-end games is worthwhile and the big
Japanese games still have a future this
week Microsoft released their huge Xbox
one update and teased the possibility of
external storage you can get the full
list of bits and bobs on gamespot but
the most interesting elements are the
new party chat mode and there's a new
multiplayer functionality the item
causing the most buzz though is this
whole possible external storage deal
which is naturally causing some of you
to grumble about not seeing it sooner
while others like NC burner on gamespot
have said wonderful to see how fast the
system is progressing as usual Microsoft
is making a system that will only get
better over time let me know your
thoughts on this one in the comments
last up it's the Batman obviously but
then Arkham Knight has been announced
and everybody seems pretty damn excited
the ps4 xbox one and pc game has plenty
of familiar and not so familiar faces
like Harley Quinn and scarecrow it'll
also have a bigger playground of world
although Gotham City is set to be in its
natural state of total peril you'll be
equipped with all your gadgets and the
epic Batmobiles are hopefully corruption
and crime won't be too much of a problem
this will be the last installment
according to dev Rocksteady and
co-founder ceptin Hill says they want to
go out in style be sure to let me know
your thoughts on any or all of today's
stories either in the comment section
down below or you can do so on my
Twitter where I'm as jess McDonald this
week on site Danny goes over games he's
never finished I chat about awesome
gifts for the gamer in your life and the
lobby has an awesome feature on Dark
Souls 2 that is it for me for the week
but thank you very much for watching I
hope you have lovely and save weekends
and i'll catch you on Monday